[Musik]
hey was geht ab und bekommen bei neuen
videos werden auch besondere ich wollte
eigentlich mit diesem sonntag mal eine
kleine auszeit nehmen und kein video
hochladen
allerdings habe ich mir oder ich habe
mich eigentlich gestern dazu
entschlossen einfach mal das video zu
machen weiß nicht einfach so unnormal
aufträgt ehrlich kein erster sagen ich
bin youtuber ich mache eigentlich nur so
mein ding und ich müsse mich nirgendwo
ein wenn ich jetzt da mal dies gibt oder
sonstwas oder irgendeine geschichte auf
youtube gibt es ja genug mit der man mal
die ein oder andere ndlich abstauben
kann so wie das der viele machen ich
hasse auch diese ganzen news über die
sich nur dadurch definieren andere in
ihren videos schlecht machen und dadurch
kommen die dann an reichweite so was du
nicht absolut scheiße aber es gibt eine
sache die ich noch schlimmer finde und
das ist zurzeit auch wenn ich das jetzt
erst für viele von euch sicherlich nicht
so gut anhört weil ich weiß auch ich hab
ja auch viele jüngere zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen und der ein oder andere
von euch mark die bis juli verlässt
bestimmt sehr oder seien davon aber baby
regt mich gerade definitiv noch mehr auf
und dazu würde ich einem ein paar worte
sagen ja erst wahrscheinlich alle
mitbekommen sie hat ja ihren songs
veröffentlicht sehr sehr viele haben
dazu auch schon ein video gemacht und
dazu ihre meinung gesagt und es gibt
auch viele videos die sich mit meiner
meinung zum großen teil überschneiden
aber ich habe dennoch eine sehr wichtige
frage so an baby und ich verstehe nicht
wieso man das so macht wie dieses wasser
darüber was was man sich so dabei denkt
ich weiß sehr genau wie die branche
abläuft wieder was funktioniert so und
deswegen sitze ich hier und gucke mir
das an was da abgeht und es ist einfach
ich frage mich warum wieso es tut mir
sehr leid ok fangen wir mal so ich dann
erstmal sagen folgten respekt das video
ging ja wirklich viral ich würde mal
sagen das hatte an einem tag mehr
durchgemacht als zb der neue song von
erzieherinnen hochgeladen hat nach einem
tag zehn millionen und wie die hat ja
irgendwie schon zwölf millionen oder was
weiß ich wie viele auf jeden fall mehr
kraft ich glaube die war in jedem land
das es so gibt es den trend
und das muss man erstmal schaffen die
frage ist jetzt nur mehr das auch genau
so passiert wenn sie ein wirklich
akzeptabel akzeptabel wenn wir ein
wirklich akzeptabel song veröffentlicht
hatte der hat natürlich seine zwei
300.000 witzig macht aber vielleicht
auch die drei oder 400.000 das ist ja an
sich nichts neues wenn youtube musik
macht wie das erstmal tod gerettet nur
was ich nicht verstehe
bibi hat ein tolles management die sich
glaube ich auch mit musik sehr gut
auskennen und dazu haben schon sehr
viele youtube ausgesagt wie kann man so
ein und gesund wie kann man so eine
scheiße veröffentlichen weil ich denke
mir so ganz ehrlich als ich meinen
ersten song gemacht habe ich habe ihn so
ein paar freunden von mir gezeigt was
hältst du davon haben gesagt ja es gar
nicht schlecht und haben gesagt ist
scheiße und ganz ehrlich wenn man weiß
doch jeder der ihn hört kann jedoch
sofort sagen das ist die größte rolle
aber es wurde ja trotzdem hochgeladen
und das ist für mich so ein grund warum
ich denke das ist halt alles vollkommen
berechnet das war aufhält ausgelegt dass
wir auf hughes ausgelegt halt einfach
wieder dieses typische wasser es kotzt
mich einfach so krass an so dieser
krasse kommerz der heißt dahinter steht
so und ich finds halt mittlerweile
wirklich täglich der das ganze ja auch
irgendwie angeklickt und hatten so eine
aussage getroffen von wegen ja bestellt
euch das bitte alle vor weil sonst
könnte es ja weg sein wo ich mir denke
das macht gar keinen sinn einfach aus
dem grund wenn die nachfrage in heiß
dann wird es dorthin produziert dann hat
man vielleicht ist sich am ersten tag
sondern erst am dritten aber ihre ganzen
kleineren zuschauerin die wollen das
natürlich haben obwohl sie den song
nicht mal gehört haben das wäre ja
genauso wenn ich mir irgendwas cooles
kaufen würde oder ich denke es ist was
cooles für sagen wir mal 50 euro und
macht es dann auf und da etwas ganz
anderes drin so komplett dürfen das ist
doch einfach nur dumm und es regt mich
einfach so auf wie man als mensch ich
versteh ich würde ich das alles so
machen wie sie hält man hat doch allein
von menschlichen übels schlechtes
gewissen oder ich kann mir ganz ehrlich
sofort das gespräch mit ihr management
so verlaufen ist so baby ich habe echt
klasse idee für dich und war
wir machen mit dir jetzt soll ich weiß
wenn ich das jedoch bestimmt jede menge
weg geben oder wie wir aber ganz ehrlich
du wirst dafür auch noch kein 300.000
euro bekommen kinder dann mach ich das
okay wir zehnter erstmal kurs auch der
song ist scheiße wasser baby am sorgen
beigetragen gar nicht wie wir hat den
song nicht geschrieben das ist dann zwar
wie die stimme aber die wurde ja ins
unendliche bearbeitet wenn man der
einheit ich habe mir gedacht ich dein
ernst also an sich kann man sagen wie
wir es einfach nur da es heute auch gut
nur leistung einfach nur da aber es
funktioniert ich kenne wirklich hier im
juli über den erfolg ich könnte jeden
youtube renner mal cooles förderverein
hat und dafür viel geld bekommt oder
sogar keine frage und auch was die wie
lang ich hatte wirklich mal falcon
respekt ich meine das ist ja kraft was
sie an followern hat wie das alles läuft
wie sie nicht präsentiert und sie weiß
genau wie es funktioniert aber in
letzter zeit finde ich das wie sie es
macht einfach nur eklig und ganz ehrlich
an die jüngeren beschert euch doch nicht
so eine scheiße vor oder sonst wo auf
wenn ihr sie noch gefeiert oder so aber
das war ja irgendwie bei itunes auf
platz 2 oder selbst stört oder platz
drei und das ist ja toll für mich krank
so kann man ganz einfach so sagen das
ist gestört also meine frage ist einfach
wie weit geht man damit man geld
verdienen
ganz ehrlich hast du du musst doch ein
mega schlechtes gewissen oder besteht
mit dem video eigentlich selber da wie
der grösste fordert weiter einfach nicht
gut ist man kann ja sagen sie verkauft
so dass wird grenzt schon fast an
prostitution für mich so dass wir
einfach so nach dem motto ja für geld
mache ich alles und das finde ich sehr
schade und ich frage mich wie man da
kein schlechtes gewissen haben kann und
wie man da nicht irgendwann mal selber
merkt das kannst du nicht machen das
kann man einfach nicht machen
das war meine meinung dazu das muss ich
jetzt einfach mal gesagt haben weil ich
so traurig finde also bitte bestellt
euch diese zeit sind nicht ganz ehrlich
antreibt man gerne eure meinung in die
kommentare lese ich mir selber gerne
vieles durch wir sehen uns dann dienstag
wieder haut rein